welcome
everyone to yet another topic on junit
tutorial now in this one we are going to
talk about what exactly is the junit uh
tool all about and how we can do various
kind of
test implementations with the help of
junit so let's talk about the agenda
which we are going to cover here now in
this one specifically we are going to
talk about like
what exactly is j unit uh what is this
particular framework all about
then we are going to talk about j unit
installation how we can do the
installation of j unit and what
are the different steps we can get
involved on that and then we are going
to talk about like
the features of junit what are the
different uh typical features of junit
are are about
then junit annotations we're going to
talk about and then junit
in java and the actual implementations
some
tutorials or some demos on how to
implement junit with eclipse
so these are some of the main topics
which we are going to cover all together
over here as such
now let's talk about what exactly is the
junit tool all about like
what are the different things we can
implement with the help of this tool
here
so junit is basically a kind of unit
testing framework which is there for the
java
so it's kind of a default offering for
the java programming language that we
can use the chair unit
for the unit testing framework for
performing the unit testing
now the main benefit of the junit is
like it's
using the same syntax like a java
programming language
so it makes it very easy for a java
developer to write and execute the test
cases
so most of the times when the developers
are going to work on the java
programming languages
so they prefer that junit as a default
unit testing framework for them because
they get the language advantage they get
the easily integrations and the eclipse
so those benefits helps the developers
to decide junit
specifically for writing the test cases
and running the test cases there
now whenever these test cases are
actually being executed whenever you add
up a new piece of source code
so all the unit test cases will be
executed will be again executed there
every time when you run a new build so
all the unit test cases gets executed
but you also need to take care that if
you are adding up a new functionalities
you also have to add the corresponding
test cases to that
so increasing more and more code will uh
will be done by the developers but at
the same time
you have to sync or you have to keep
your test cases up to date
also and as a part of every build each
and every test cases will be re-executed
every time you're doing the build five
times
six times a day every time the all unit
test cases will be executed over there
and the response will be given back
right now let's talk about what exactly
is the unit testing
now unit testing refers to the testing
of these small small modules or the
small piece of
chunks or the codes here now it's
basically used to
have the early identification of the
defects and the bugs because
you cannot simply rely on the qa team to
perform the testing
and then provide the feedback whereas on
the uh with the help of this unit
testing framework we can
immediately get the feedback right away
once we are
running the test cases immediately we
will be able to know like these are the
different test cases which we have
got over here now the developers don't
even have to
spend more time on fixing the bugs and
issues because
these test cases will help them with the
easy and the fast feedback
so according to that they can fix the
bugs and they can take the decision
whether the
source code is working fine as expected
or there is any kind of
issues as such present with this one so
unit test casing is something which
is very important from the developer's
perspective also because it helps the
developers to understand that they
whether they have written a successful
code
or if there is any kind of scope of
issues or bugs over here
also it the successful unit test cases
increases the overall confidence of the
developers because it
increases the overall performance and
the quality of the product also
so by having the successful executions
of the unit test cases
developers can understand that yes the
source code is working fine as expected
and there is no scope of bugs or any
issues as such with this source code
here
so that's the main benefit which we get
with unit testing that with this
fast feedback channel we will be able to
take
uh the decisions whether the source code
is ready for the production environment
deployment or not so that's a main
benefit
which we get with the unit testing here
now of course this can be done in two
ways manual testing and automatic
testing
now in case of manual testing you have
to do this thing manually
within a manual tester or a manual
testing approach
and in this one you will not be
depending on any kind of automated tool
which can be scheduled or which can be
executed in non-interactive manner on
the other hand
automatic test case is something which
is used to be executed using the
tool and uh it is something which is
being done so that you will be able to
get
the complete automation there is no
manual efforts which is required
as such you are going to have like
complete uh deployment and automations
being done
as such in this case so automated
testing is something in which you will
be giving more focus on the automated
automation tools
you may be having one or a couple of
tools which using which you can write
the
automated test cases and you can perform
the complete automation
in case of manual testing it's quite uh
you know less reliable because
you are dependent on the uh a particular
tester
which can ha perform the testing
according to his
efforts and it's quite a time consuming
also because you can only run the test
cases for
probably eight to nine hours per a day
whereas on the other hand the automated
test case is something which is
quite reliable because it does not
depends on a human so so requirements so
it can be done like 24 cross 7 so
anytime you can run those
test cases and that's the reason why
these test cases are quite faster
as compared to any other manual testing
approach here
so junit test cases and the automated
test cases
really helps the developers and the qa
professionals to test the
source code much faster as compared to
the manual testing
now let's talk about the joint
installation now as part the of the
installation of junit you don't require
to install any exe file or any kind of
program there
there are a couple of jar files which is
required which needs to be there into
the
class path so that every time when you
write some junit test cases you should
be able to refer those jar files
because without having those jar files
into your class part of your project
you will not be able to run the change
in test cases so
that's the only dependency you require
if you are running a maven build
then these dependencies will be added up
into the powered xml file
if you are referring or doing the build
from the eclipse or
doing the development from the ecrips
then you have to put up these jar files
into the
class part of the project so that these
jar files can be loaded up and dj unit
can be referred over here
so the installation is pretty
straightforward but let's see like what
are the different steps we need to
follow
now as a pre-request of understanding
the demo about junit the first initial
two things is like
you require a jdk to be installed now
you can download the jdk8 over here from
this oracle website
and uh this is something which you can
download for the windows or whatever
platform you have
you can pretty much install it for
whatever platform is there
so for windows platform you can download
for 32-bit and the 64-bit both option
over here
and once it's installed so you should be
able to use the eclipse latest tool
now um all you need to do is that you
need to go to eclipse.org
and there you can download the latest
version of the
eclipse now these two main things which
you require because
eclipse will be required for creating
the change unit test cases and of course
how a kind of ide where you can run some
test cases change your test cases and
all
and then oracle is something which is
required as a runtime for
running the jdk also and the junit uh
test cases also and eclipse here so
that's a pre-request which we got over
here in this
one so i have already got these two
things installed into my system and i
have
eclipse there so let's move on to the
eclipse and see that how it
goes on there but before that you also
require the junit
jar files because in order to have a
particular junit framework loaded up
we require some uh particular files
jar files over here in this case so i
can just search for junit
four over here and when you search for j
unit four so what happens like
this particular page will help you or
give you all the details about the chat
unit 4.
now you can go for the version notes of
the different different versions but uh
if you want to download
all you need to do is like you can say
like download and install and the moment
you go there so it will give you the
details now there are two jar files
which is required
junit.jar file is required over here
j uh hamcrest iphonecode.jar file these
two jar files are required here
if you want to download it into the test
class path if
you feel that you want to uh use a maven
based uh project then in that case
you have to specifically go for this
dependency in the palm file
and according to that that particular
version will be downloaded and will be
referred over there
so these are the ways that how you can
get the particular softwares the
required things into the place so i'm
going to put up this jar files into a
location so that
i should be able to get the particular
details
stored and i can refer to them into my
eclipse
so i'm going to download this one here
from the
maven central
so i'm going to download this jar file
and then i'm going to go back
and create hyphen code so that also i
want to download
download chart so these two jar files i
have uh
downloaded and i will be referring these
ones into my project
because these are the ones which has
been required into my project as such
so let's go back to the eclipse and uh
let's place this jar files into a
location so that
into my class path i can refer the
complete folder with all these two java
files inside that so let's go ahead with
that
so let's create a particular new project
over here so we'll go for new
java project and here i can give it like
a simple one
a simple project name i can provide here
and
jdk i'm using like 1.8 so that's the jdk
version which i have utilized over here
and then folish so this is the project
which i have got like in the source
directory
now i'm going to create a simple file
over here
a new class file over here so i'll
create it like
j unit class
so i'm going to create a class over here
in this one
and of course i need to have a
particular white main also over here in
this
specific class over here because this is
the initial class i'm trying to create
over here in this one
i can create a custom particular methods
also over here but uh let's see like if
we can execute or we can run some
particular functions as such over here
now i'm going to declare a function over
here
public void
junit method
so i'm just going to create a method
over here
i'm just going to run a particular
print statement over here
executing j unit
test cases right
now this is a kind of a method which is
there which of course i can run into my
uh public void main and this function
will be executed uh will be called upon
over here
now the thing is that uh right now uh
since it's just a normal function but
the moment i convert it like i have uh
at the rate test mentioned over here so
what will happen like this
will be converted into the form of a
test cases
now of course like right now there is no
imports which is available there
as part of this one so you can see that
the uh the
the time i have added this annotation at
the read test
i will be able to see like yes add
junit 4 library to the build path
is something which is coming up over
here or it's saying like add junit 5 so
whatever the library you feel that you
want to add you can do
that and that particular library will be
added up okay
now let's go for the junit 4 library
here the moment i do that what will
happen
you will see some changes first you will
see the changes in the top
saying that import orj dot junit dot
test
that's a first import and second import
will be like junit 4 you will see like
these two jar files
is automatically being picked up by the
eclipse
now even if you don't download these jar
files this is the main benefit of the
eclipse that these are already
a part of the plugins you can see their
paths that these are already installed
in the
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more plugins directory so the
moment you use
these uh particular methods that you
want to use the junit
these will be automatically imported
over here into your system
now you can just simply call this method
into the main
void mean and then the specific method
will be executed as a form of test cases
so this is the mechanism that how you
will be
setting up the project initially you got
the imports you got the
uh particular annotations configured and
with that
the uh specific jar files will be
automatically being added up into your
class path
whatever the java files we added up we
downloaded previously we can also
have that added up into the custom class
path we can modify this
build path of junit 4 which is coming up
automatically we can just simply say
right click
build path and configure so this jf unit
4 we can actually import we can remove
it from our system and we can
add our external jar files also into the
uh build path or the class path over
here so that depends upon you
that how you want to perform the
customizations around that part but yes
the particular main benefit of using the
eclipse is that it's already having the
junit plugin installed
both four and five version is installed
whatever version you feel that you want
to include
it will be included and the plugins are
already installed so you don't even have
to download
the jar files manually so that's how you
will be able to do a very basic initial
setup of junit and how a basic project
can be created over here in case of
junit
in the upcoming demos we'll see like how
we can execute this particular test
cases and we'll get the response
we'll come to that point so let's go
back to the main content right so that
was the
uh junior installation demo which we saw
and we saw like how we can
put up or load the jar files related to
changing it into a class path pattern
you can resolve
the basic uh you know features about the
chair unit about the test cases
now let's talk about some of the certain
features of the chair unit here
now there are a lot of features which we
get primary with the chair unit let's
discuss about that one by one
so the very first feature about junit is
that it's an
open source network now it's something
which is available as an open source to
you
uh we have also seen the installation so
you don't have to
really go for any kind of uh license or
something like that so you can do
any number of test cases with this
particular tool and this
uh specific automation tool here you can
automate it into jenkins no way you
require any kind of license around this
so um these can be easily integrated
these are already or part of most of the
latest eclipse installation so you don't
even have to
configure these manually because it's
already a part of your system
right second is that it provides
annotations now
main annotation we have already seen in
the previous case that when
we converted a normal function or a
normal method into the test method by
using an annotation called
at the right test so it provides a
mechanism to identify that which
particular method is a test method
and which method is a normal method
according to our classes
so these annotations really help us to
identify the methods also
and it provides us the flexibility that
these particular methods are not the
normal methods you need to execute you
need to run it in the form of test cases
so that
identification is something we will be
able to do with the help of these
annotations here
uh also it provides the excitations uh
to identify like what exactly
the results are there because uh
definitely when we are running the test
cases
test cases we need to assert that what
should be the value
so using the assert uh you know we can
ascertains we can actually compare that
okay
this method is giving this value suppose
there is an addition uh
method which is available there which is
giving like a plus b is equal to
c so c is like 5 plus 15 is 20.
so with the help of asset i'm saying
like whatever the response i'm going to
get from the function
when i give the values a and b as 5 and
15 so that should be 20 value
so in the asset i can hard code like
okay this is the value this is the
response which i should be getting
and once the function is executed i
should be able to get this particular
output as in 20 over here
so that comparison when you do you will
be able to understand
easily that yes when we are doing the
asset i'm getting the proper response
i'm getting the proper output over here
so assertion is something which is very
important to compare the things to
compare the inputs which we are getting
from the application source code
next it provides the test runner so we
can basically
run the test runners over here to
execute the test cases so
you can configure this within the
pipelines you can configure it with
eclipse and
various automations during the build
automations also you can configure it
so that flexibility you will be able to
get with these test runners here
and it also allows you provide a better
feedback channel because
it acts like a very good feedback
provider because the moment you are done
with the development
you will be able to get an instant
feedback so the overall quality of the
code is going to be increased in this
case
and that's definitely helpful for you
because with this uh
approach with this junit uh framework
you will be able to get a quite
faster and a perfect uh code writing
tool or a quality tool which is
available there so
definitely the overall quality of the
code is going to improve
with the help of this junit framework
and it provides the automations also
because these unit uh
test cases are having the flexibility
that you can configure it within the
pipelines
you can automate it with the help of
this framework that you can completely
help
or you can have a complete automated
workflow with the help of this
particular framework and it provides you
an instant feedback the feedback channel
is quite
instant in case of this j unit
now let's talk about the junit
annotations we have already seen like
the main benefit of the annotation is to
define or to provide the metadata about
the methods to the different ones
so annotations also refer to the
synthetical uh
method data added to the java source
code so having
a particular better of feasibility and
identification is also quite easy so
also the overall structure of the source
code can be done in a better way
and the readability is also good when we
talk about the annotations here
the biggest main difference between the
uh junit and dj unit 3 was the in
the introduction of the junit
annotations
so uh earlier before j2 unit 3 we were
not able to identify like if
this is in kind of a test method or this
is a kind of a source method over here
so that identifications is quite easy
after the involvement or the
introduction of the
junit 4 framework over here
also like this is something which is
really helpful to us to see like how
exactly
we can overall read the overall source
code because you have so many so many
source code
there present to your project so
annotation should be able to
uh you know help you to identify the
that these are the main portions with
these are the components which is part
of the
unit test cases not the actual source
code so at the right test is something
which is
uh you know going to tell us that the
the specific method with the public void
declaration can be run or can be
executed as a test cases this is not a
simple method this is not an application
source code method this is a test method
over here
now at the it before is something which
is uh used to
run some statement before each and every
test case is executes
maybe having some additional or initial
connectivity is something you can do
with the help of
add that it before at the rate after is
something which you can do after the
execution of the test cases like
some statements which you want to
execute after the uh test cases so
that's something you can
do or you can go with the help of at the
date after
and at the rate ignores is something
which you can configure if you feel like
during the
test execution you feel to ignore some
statement so that's the way you can use
the
ad that it ignores there so add that it
ignores add the date after
add that it before and at the rate test
these are the four
annotations which is being used most of
the time into your
junit test cases right let's talk about
some bit more
now add that it before is something
which is being used to execute the
classes
uh some statement before even you know
any kind of test class executes
so not only uh you know before executing
any method this is something before
even loading up any kind of uh test
classes so before at the at the rate
before class is being used
similarly at the rate after will be
there to execute it after all the test
classes
and uh if we have a timeout configured
so what will have that
we will be able to set up a timeout
while executing the test cases so
timeout value can be configured over
here and then
uh if you feel like if you want to
handle some exceptions
during the test execution so that's
where we can use this custom annotations
over here
to have the exceptions handled or
configured over here in this one
so these are some of the very important
annotations which is available there on
the chair unit perspective
now let's talk about some another demo
on chair unit testing in the java like
how we can
pretty much configure the test cases in
junit for a programming language called
java
and how we can get along or get execute
those things so now we are going to see
like how exactly we can
you know go for the execution of some
java files onto our command line and how
we can
uh using the command line run some
execution of the test cases
typically we do it from the eclipse but
uh from the command line also we are
going to see like how
exactly uh you know we are performing
the setup and the executions over here
now what we really need to do is like we
need to see like how we can proceed
further with the execution so i'm going
to open this
uh particular java file over here so to
get a better understanding here
so i'm going to use the junit uh
class over here in this case so we are
having a couple of imports
these are the standard imports so you
can do like orj.jstar also if you don't
want to go for the specific
imports here now here we are going to
create a test unit
as an uh sample class and in this one we
got the
void main over here which is the main
portion of any kind of class here
the only thing which we got over here is
that we have created a test
method over here called test print
message
so we are assigning a value called
message a variable over here as in
simply learn
now what happens like uh we will be able
to uh like you know do the assert equals
over here
that if the value of message is like
simply learn
so it will be able to help us with the
proper
output and uh there will be no errors as
such over here
so everything will be smooth and that's
what we are trying to execute over here
in this case
and we are running into the null void
that these are the test cases we want to
run or we want to execute over here
now all we need to do is we need to
compile this one we
really need to compile this scale test
cases over here
this file and then we have to run that
one so for that let me open the command
prompt
so now in this case we will be using the
java c command prompt here
and we will be copying the j unit into
the uh
class path so that we will not be able
to get any kind of
class not found issues over here so test
unit junit.java we are going to run so
if there is no
exceptions as such we will be able to
get no errors here
now i'm going to run the uh particular
class file with the help of java command
because java c is to
convert the dot java file to the dot
class file the compile format and then
in order to run the dot class file we
have to go for the
java command line here now this means
that
there is no issues as such with the test
cases
and everything is working fine as
expected over here in this one
so the assert equals is going to help
you to identify that if
the execution is proper and let's say
like if we put up some content like
some different content over here in this
asset equals
so i'm going to again execute this one
so that i will be able to see like if
you know what will happen that if this
message value and this value does not
matches like in normal situations it
will say like okay
uh the uh particular uh you know output
is going up and
there is no errors as such right so
let's see like what exactly uh it will
happen that if we
go for the executions like if we save
this file in such a way that we are
providing some wrong inputs and what
will happen to our asset equal over here
so i'm going to again compile the file
here so again a new class file will be
available
and this time i'm going to execute this
class file again over here in this case
and the moment you did it the assert
will give you the
comparison over here saying that there
is a failure of the comparison
why there is a failure of the comparison
because according to the code base
it was expecting the value called simply
learn
but it simply got the value called
simply learn one two
which means that your test cases over
here got failed down
so this is the real way that how you
will be providing the comparison
like what you should be putting up to
the application and what kind of
response you should be getting in
in return of that so that's where you
will be able to provide a proper and a
complete
comparison here which will help you to
understand that what exactly output
you're going to get over here
and that's where the output will be
completely
uh available to you and you will be able
to get a proper output as such here
right so this is the way that how the
comparison will be performed and how you
will be able to see like these two
comparison being done here
as such so this is the way that how
you're going to run the test cases in
the form
of the from the command line here so
let's go back to the main
document right now the next one which we
got over here is the changer test cases
using the eclipse because from the
command line we saw like using the comma
line we can do
but we got like so many test cases which
is available there so it's not easy for
us to run those one by one
so we will be doing it through the
eclipse so that we can see like how the
execution can be really done
and we can get a hold of those
particular components so let's go back
to the eclipse and this time we are
going to run the test cases in the
eclipse here
now let's create a new project again
here
j unit
project right and finish
so a new j project a junit project will
be created
now in this one you can see like there
is no executables libraries for
junit but you can include it now also
but i'm going to do it later on so i'll
go for the
j unit project class
right so this is a kind of a test class
here so i'm not going to put the
null the public void mean over here in
this one so
finish now in this case what i'm going
to do is like i'm going to
you know replace this content over here
so uh
with this particular ones and
going to have some basic core base added
up over here
so i'm going to import some uh
particular junit
uh libraries over here so over here like
oj.j unit i'm going to import these ones
and i got like this
class over here junit uh you know
project so i just have to rename it a
little bit so that it can be the
name of the actual class uh name here so
that's fine
so everything is fine but the only thing
is that we are getting some failures and
problems over here
because it's not able to identify these
specific
junit related executables like the
functions and the methods
for this one again the previous like
previous case you have to do the
uh particular addition of the library to
the build path
so that you will be able to have like
these automatically resolved over here
in this one
right so you can see now that the unit 4
started reflecting over here in this
case and you did not got any kind of
errors now over here in this one so you
can simply save this
and now you can you are good to go for
running the executions over here
so you can simply say like right click
over here
run s and change unit test and when you
do that
on the left hand side you will be able
to get a little bit different viewpoint
over here
which says like yes test and score j
unit is something which is executed
perfectly fine
if for any reason let's say like i
change the value of
string one here as in string string1
just an
typo error i'm trying to do here so that
i can show you that how the test cases
really fails
so assert equals is basically helping to
find out that if
the comparison between the two
attributes is correct
that means that uh you know the inputs
which we are putting up and whatever the
output we are getting
it's both the same here when you do that
you will say like there is an
failure over here to the test cases now
i'm seeing the
failure trace over here so i'll just
move this one to the console view
so it says like it should be like string
but i got like string one over here
which is causing the problem here
because of the typo error which i did
the whole execution of the test cases
got failed
so i'm just going to revert my changes
back here and again from the test cases
it will all be okay right now again over
here so that's a main reason that how
the execution really happens in the
overall
mechanism and the system can be
implemented over here in this case
so that's how we basically go on and we
execute some
junit test cases here so this is the
basic uh
demos which we did about the junit and
how exactly it
goes for the implementation of the unit
test cases here
so that's it for this topic thanks
everyone
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here